Towards the end of the twentieth century,
a celebrated Romanian-French philosopher
was invited to speak in Zurich. He
was introduced with rhetorical pomp and flattering
comparisons to the likes of Kierkegaard and
Schopenhauer. The speaker smiled, and immediately
confounded his German interpreter by beginning
his presentation with the words: ÔMais je
ne suis quŐun dŽconneurŐ / ÔBut IŐm
just a jokerŐ. A few of his critics might
agree, but they would be wrong. For Emil
Cioran is very much worthy of inclusion in
the line of the great French and European
moral philosophers and writers of maxims stretching
back to Montaigne, Chamfort, Pascal and La
Rochefoucauld. Cioran was born in Rasinari,
Romania, in April 1911. His father was a Greek
Orthodox priest. Both facts were to be key
in his later work. The writerŐs Romanian
origins are often taken as the source of a
brooding, Romantic, fatalistic temperament
while his fatherŐs ecclesiastical calling
finds echoes in his sonŐs unswerving preoccupation
with themes of religion, sainthood and the
dangers and joys of atheism.
In 1934,
at the age of only 23, he published his first
book in Romanian, On the Heights of Despair.
The book contains in embryo much of the lucidly
bleak, nihilistic thinking that heŐd develop
throughout his life. He explained that writing
had been an alternative to shooting himself.
This is an author to read at moments of despair
and melancholy. He doesnŐt depress us, merely
makes us feel less alone with our sorrows.
Here is a peak inside his work: ÔIt is not
worth the bother of killing yourself, since
you always kill yourself too late.Ő ÔOnly
optimists commit suicide, optimists who no
longer succeed at being optimists. The others,
having no reason to live, why would they have
any to die?Ő ÔWrite books only if you
are going to say in them the things you would
never dare confide to anyone.Ő And: ÔWhat
do you do from morning to night?Ő ÔI endure
myself.Ő 1937 proved a pivotal year for
Cioran. He moved to Paris and soon became
a French citizen. He never returned to the
country of his birth. It was a move that provided
him with another reason to be melancholic: exile.
And yet he asserted that anyone who doesnŐt
feel themselves to be an exile has no imagination.
ÔOnly the village idiot thinks they belong,Ő
he noted. Cioran sat out the Second World
War in Paris. In its aftermath, he approached
the famous publishing house, Gallimard, with
his first work in French, A Short History
of Decay, published in 1949. Writing in French
was he said, Ôlike writing a love letter
with a dictionaryŐ. The book became a bestseller,
the first in a series of devastatingly wicked
and dark texts composed mainly of aphorisms
and tart short essays. Each title comes as
a provocation or a punch: Syllogisms of Bitterness,
The Temptation to Exist and his masterpiece:
The Trouble with Being Born. Each book deals
relentlessly with themes of illness, death
and suicide. It was a rather touching irony
that the author lived to the ripe old age
of 84. By the time Cioran died in 1995, he
had become a cult in France, attracting the
sort of faddish attention he witheringly denounced
in his work. Every life, he maintained, is
utterly peculiar Đ and wholly unimportant.
In the age of Walt Disney, this kind of darkness
matters. CioranŐs writing belongs in the
line of those great aloof European miserabilists,
including La Rochefoucauld, Chamfort, Leopardi,
Nietzsche and Beckett. Like them, he saw civilization
as an absurd distraction from the ultimate
meaninglessness of existence. ÔOnly an idiot
could think there is a point to any of this,Ő
he insisted. But he always kept his wit and
good cheer. One of his greatest sources of
sorrow was that he couldnŐt sleep very well
Đ and was often up at 3am. HeŐd walk around
the streets of Paris until dawn. He noted
sardonically in The Trouble with Being Born,
ÔWhat is that one crucifixion compared to
the daily kind any insomniac suffers?Ő Cioran
was obsessed by suicide. But better to live,
he wrote, and yet think and act as though
one were already dead. After all, he said:
why deprive oneself of the consoling idea
of no longer being around? ÔContinuing to
Live is possible only because of the deficiencies
of our imagination and our memories.Ő he
wrote. ÔIŐm simply an accident. Why take
it all so seriously?Ő But suicide was a
constant relief as an idea: ÔWe dread the
future only when we are not sure we can kill
ourselves when we want to.Ő ÔHaving always
lived in fear of being surprised by the worst,
I have tried in every circumstance to get
a head start, flinging myself into misfortune
long before it occurred.Ő Our age is notably
optimistic and it makes us suffer hugely from
being so. We are all, in private, a lot sadder
than we are allowed to admit. Writers like
Cioran provide an occasion for the sadness
inside all of us to be communally expressed
and thereby a little, but only a little, diminished
and softened. In his beautiful book, The Trouble
with Being Born, Cioran wrote: ÔI can be
friends with people only when they are at
their lowest point and have neither the desire
nor the strength to restore their habitual
sentimental illusions.Ő ItŐs precisely
in that kind of mood Đ into which all thoughtful
people must sink on a fairly regular basis
Đ that we can be blessed to find the dark
and consoling works of Emil Cioran waiting for
us.
We love bringing you these films, if you want to help us to keep bringing you these films.
If you want to helps us to keep bringing you thoughtful content.  Please consider supporting us
by visiting our shop at the link on your screen now.